aquí
[Música]
[Aplausos]
mentirosa mentirosa así me dijo mi mamá
una mañana de reyes yo era chiquita
tenía cinco o seis años todos habíamos
pedido mis amiguitas y yo te regalo una
bicicleta sin rueditas
y la noche previa me dormí con una
ilusión me despierto temprano salto de
la cama
voy a buscar los zapatitos nada por acá
nada por allá
no tenía la bicicleta
el sentimiento de inferioridad que tuve
fue tan enorme que creí que nunca más
iba a poder salir de mi casa mientras
por los ventanales veía que las que sí
tenían la bicicleta se reían juzgaban la
acariciaban
y en esa desesperación
inventé
mi primera mentira oficial y pública
a propósito de eso saben ustedes cuál
fue
la recuerdan
porque si no sucedió esta es una buena
ocasión
la cuestión es que llamas armadita yo
con mi mentira salvo
padre madre y la bici
no digo no tengo la bici pero
melchor me prestó su divina corona
totalmente tapizada de esmeraldas de
brillantes de diamantes y de rubíes y
ese fue el mejor regalo que puede
recibir
no tiene ni idea la reacción de mis
amiguitas
desoladas y envidiosas
tiraron las bicicletas
entrar llorando a la casa mientras
decían porque a mí no porque a mí no yo
me había puesto de espaldas a mi casa
porque no quería que mi mamá viera lo
que yo iba a ser pero vio todo
así que salió furiosa me levanto del
codo como un viento mientras me decía
mentirosa mentirosa
caramba digo yo yo mentirosa mentirosa
yo y que de los reyes magos y que de
papá noel
y que de ratoncito pérez y que de la
cigüeña porque si vamos a hablar de
mentiras nos mintieron a todos por eso
digo ni todas las mentiras son tan malas
ni todas las verdades son tan buenas
y que es la mentira que es desde el
punto de vista psicológico
es un mecanismo de defensa que se nos
arma ante el temor a una pérdida de un
contacto de una relación de un prestigio
de algo que queremos conservar y esa
característica la hace universal porque
no respeta credos ni culturas ni edades
ni parentescos nada y ya desde pequeños
aprendemos a la par de la verdad y de la
mentira los adultos decimos a los niños
que están muy bien decir la verdad pero
el niño en su candor cuando dice mamá
estás engordando dejar de comer tanto o
bueno quién le pasa a la abuela está
enferma le falta un hueso
ya sabemos lo que pasa reprende en retos
prohibición no digas estas cosas
entonces a ella desde pequeñitos
aprendemos que muchas veces es
preferible callar la verdad y usar a ver
una mentira
necesaria no para evitar que nos retén
ay mamá
qué linda que estás vamos a la casa de
la abuelita
una mentira protectora
y eso sabe yo lo veo mucho además de
verlo en la vida especialmente en el
consultorio cuando alguien tiene una
pareja celosa te juro a mi amor que no
me puse la minifalda
pero qué sé yo querida quien demandó
whatsapp estoy tan ocupado para evitar
más problemas de los que ya hay
una mentira piadosa
cuando tenemos a alguien que queremos
mucho y está pasando una situación muy
difícil la elevamos para saber que
mañana será mejor
o una mentira social porque de verdad es
insoportable andar por la vida diciendo
y escuchando todas las verdades hola que
tal todo bien y todo bien y seguimos
nuestro camino como vemos tenemos muchos
modos de escaparle a la verdad
pero al fin y al cabo quién dispone
quién decide lo que es verdad y lo que
es mentira
y qué decir de las verdades que dañan el
sincericidio del uso de la verdad
para herido para matar la autoestima del
otro para sacarnos una culpa que no la
podemos aguantar y ahí la tenemos
entronizada sin anestesia y sin tener en
cuenta si el otro está preparado para
recibirla
sincericidio
tiene la misma raíz que homicidio y que
suicidio
ustedes habrán escuchado que se dice que
la mentira tiene patas cortas
bueno a veces si por ejemplo esos casos
de personas que no les gusta el trabajo
que tiene en la familia que tienen el
sueldo que ganan el auto nada y en lugar
de cambiar se inventan una realidad
paralela y entonces dicen no porque me
va a llegar una herencia maravillosa y
entonces con eso voy a comprar el auto y
uno al principio son tan vehementes y
uno les cree pero pasa el tiempo y no
sucede nada de eso se acuerdan de el
cuento del pastorcito mentiroso yo decía
viene el lobo viene el lobo y bajaba
toda la aldea a protegerle las ovejitas
y él se moría de la risa porque era
mentira hasta que un día no lo fue
viene el lobo viene el lobo
y se quedó sin los amigos y sin las
ovejas y lo dice el refranero popular
en boca del mentiroso lo cierto se
vuelve dudoso
pero lamento decirles
que hay mentiras de patas largas
de patas muy largas me refiero
a los mentirosos profesionales a los
manipuladores emocionales a los que no
tienen sentimiento de culpa
saben perfectamente
cómo lograr su objetivo son encantadores
encantadoras seductores buena presencia
tiene una esgrima verbal que convence a
cualquiera
y nos damos cuenta a veces cuando es un
poco tarde cuando se nos adelgazo la
billetera
cuando desapareció de golpe
cuando hicimos un mal negocio
tengamos cuidado mucho cuidado porque
están en todas partes en la política
en la vida cotidiana en la vida familiar
y yo ahora quiero hablarles de la peor
quiero hablarles de la peor de las
mentiras
saben cuál es
el autoengaño
s dejarse estar ese no querer ver
parece que uno no se da cuenta se
protege un rato la persona así entonces
mira para el sudeste en lugar de mirar
al norte cierra los ojos cuando tiene
que tenerlos muy abiertos
porque hace eso
porque tiene miedo
de encontrarse con una verdad
insoportable
no me refiero solo los campos del amor
ni de los lazos sociales también me
refiero a los campos de la salud cuando
tenemos síntomas y no vamos al médico
cuando vamos al médico nos da estudios y
no hacemos los estudios o cuando los
hacemos y no los vamos a retirar y a
veces es dejarse estar
puede tener consecuencias muy dolorosas
nadie
está libre del autoengaño
así nos lo dice
el gran escritor ruso dostoievski
toda persona tiene recuerdos que
solamente compartiría con sus amigos
pero tiene otras cosas
que no compartiría ni con sus amigos
sino tan sólo consigo mismo y en
absoluto secreto
pero hay ciertas cosas
que tenemos miedo de contarnos a
nosotros mismos
por eso quiero invitarlos
hacen un recorrido por el laberinto
de las múltiples mentiras nuestras de
cada día
ustedes me dirán para qué
saben que yo creo que vale la pena
para avanzar en nuestro autoconocimiento
para saber cómo está yendo nuestra vida
estamos conformes
estamos en declive hay que dar un
volantazo porque mentimos
porque seguimos haciendo cosas que
detestamos de nosotros y las seguimos
haciendo tal vez en ese viaje en esa
travesía encontremos una llave una clave
que ilumine nuestro camino
lo hacemos
lo intentamos
[Aplausos]
[Música]
y